การวัด quantum superposition สุ่มพอๆ กับการโยนเหรียญ แต่เราจะใช้การเปรียบเทียบนั้น
ไปได้ไกลแค่ไหนก่อนที่มันจะพัง เราจะหาคำตอบวันนี้ใน Qiskit in the
Classroom ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ Qiskit in the Classroom ซีรีส์วิดีโอที่เราแยกย่อยแนวคิดพื้นฐานที่คุณ
อาจพบในคอร์สที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ Quantum Computing แต่ละวิดีโอมี interactive module ลิงก์อยู่ใน
คำอธิบายด้านล่าง อย่าลืมเช็กดูนะ วันนี้เราพูดถึงหนึ่งในหลักการหลักที่อยู่ในหัวใจของ
ทฤษฎีควอนตัมคือ superposition ในประสบการณ์ประจำวันของเรา วัตถุมักมีคุณสมบัติที่แน่นอนเสมอ ตำแหน่ง ขนาด
รูปร่าง สี ทุกอย่างเกี่ยวกับมันถูกกำหนดและแน่นอน แม้ว่าเรา ผู้สังเกต ยังไม่ได้วัดมันก็ตาม ใน
โลกควอนตัม สิ่งนี้ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นอย่างนั้น วัตถุควอนตัมสามารถอยู่ใน superposition ของ
สถานะที่อนุญาตในแบบคลาสสิกหลายสถานะ ซึ่งเมื่อถูกวัดจะ collapse แบบสุ่มไปยังสถานะใดสถานะหนึ่ง
การวัดสถานะ superposition เหมือนการโยนเหรียญ ไม่มีทางรู้ล่วงหน้าว่ามันจะออกมาแบบไหน
ความไม่แน่นอนพื้นฐานนี้เป็นด้านที่น่าอึดอัดของกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมที่แม้แต่ Einstein ก็มีปัญหา
ด้วย เขาพูดประโยคดังว่า God does not play dice เกี่ยวกับความสุ่มนี้ แต่อย่างที่เราจะเห็น พระเจ้าเล่นลูกเต๋าจริงๆ หรือใน
กรณีของเรา พระองค์โยนเหรียญ แต่ยิ่งกว่านั้น เหรียญเหล่านี้ถ่วงน้ำหนัก การวัด quantum superposition อาจคล้ายกับ
การโยนเหรียญในบางแง่ แต่ superposition เองมีความหมายลึกซึ้งและซับซ้อนกว่า
สถานะ probabilistic แบบคลาสสิก เพื่อดูสิ่งนี้ เราจะคิดถึงว่าเหรียญคลาสสิกทำงานยังไงและเปรียบเทียบสิ่งนี้กับ
quantum coin ของเราที่เราจะสำรวจโดยใช้ Qiskit บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม IBM ก่อนอื่น เหรียญคลาสสิก มัน
ง่ายมาก คุณโยนเหรียญและมันออกมาหัวหรือก้อยด้วยโอกาส 50% ของแต่ละอย่าง จริงๆ แล้วในหลักการเราสามารถ
คำนวณได้ว่าเหรียญจะลงด้านไหนถ้าเรารู้เงื่อนไขเริ่มต้นที่แม่นยำของเหรียญและรู้ว่าใช้
แรงและแรงบิดเท่าไหร่ระหว่างการโยน แต่ในทางปฏิบัติไม่มีทางรู้ล่วงหน้าว่าเหรียญจะ
ลงด้านไหน นั่นเป็นเหตุว่าทำไมเราใช้การโยนเหรียญเป็นตัวอย่างคลาสสิกของสถานะ probabilistic ที่
ผลลัพธ์สุ่มได้โดยพื้นฐาน ถ้าฉันโยนเหรียญนี้พันครั้งและบันทึกจำนวนหัวขึ้น
และหัวลง ฉันก็จะได้ histogram ที่หน้าตาประมาณนี้ ดังนั้นเรามีจำนวนนับบนแกน Y
และมันอาจเป็นหัวขึ้นหรือหัวลง และ
histogram จะแสดงว่ามีประมาณ 500 นับของแต่ละอย่าง ขึ้นอยู่กับ
ความผันผวนทางสถิติบางอย่าง เราสามารถสร้างสถานะที่คล้ายกันโดยใช้ qubit บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมของเรา เหมือนการโยนเหรียญ
qubit ยังสามารถถูกวัดใน state ที่เป็นไปได้สองอย่างคือ zero และ one ถ้าเราใช้สิ่งที่เรียกว่า Hadamard gate กับ
qubit มันจะวาง qubit ใน superposition เท่ากันของ zero และ one นี่คือ
visualization ของ circuit นั้นซึ่งเราเรียกว่า circuit diagram นี่คือ
qubit เส้นบนสุด และ operation ที่นำไปใช้กับ qubit จะปรากฏเป็นกล่องบนเส้น Hadamard gate แสดงด้วยกล่องนี้
ที่มีป้าย H และการวัดแสดงด้วยกล่องสีเทาที่มีสัญลักษณ์การวัดเล็กๆ มันส่ง
การวัดนั้นไปยัง classical bit เส้นที่มีสองเส้นนี้ ดังนั้นเนื่องจาก qubit อยู่ใน superposition เท่ากันของ 0 และ one เมื่อ
เราวัดมัน จะมีโอกาส 50% ที่เราวัดได้ zero และ 50% ที่วัดได้
one เราแสดง quantum superposition state นี้ว่า s = 1 หาร
รากที่สองของ 2 คูณ |0⟩ บวก 1 หารรากที่สองของ 2 คูณ |1⟩ โดยที่กำลังสองของแต่ละ
coefficient ซึ่งเรียกอีกอย่างว่า amplitude คือความน่าจะเป็นของการวัดแต่ละสถานะ ดังนั้น ในทางปฏิบัติการใช้ Hadamard
gate เป็น analog ของการโยนเหรียญ และเหมือนกับที่เราโยนเหรียญพันครั้งเพื่อดู
สถิติของเหรียญที่ลงหัวขึ้นหรือลง เราสามารถทำสิ่งที่คล้ายกันบน Qiskit ด้วย quantum coin ของเรา
เราจะใช้ Qiskit primitive ที่เรียกว่า sampler ซึ่งจะรัน circuit หลายครั้งเพื่อ sample สถิติ
ของสถานะที่ได้ ด้วย 1,000 sample ของ circuit ด้านบน เรามีสิ่งที่หน้าตาเหมือนกับ
histogram เหรียญคลาสสิกโดยพื้นฐาน ขึ้นอยู่กับความผันผวนทางสถิติบางอย่าง แล้วนั่นแหละเหรอ quantum
superposition เหมือนกับสถานะ probabilistic แบบคลาสสิกโดยพื้นฐาน คล้ายกับการโยนเหรียญใช่ไหม ยังไม่ค่อยแน่ นี่จะ
เป็นวิดีโอที่สั้นมากถ้ามันเป็นอย่างนั้น เพื่อดูความแตกต่างหลักแรกของเรา ฉันจะลองทำอะไรที่ต่างออกไปนิดหน่อยกับเหรียญคลาสสิกของฉัน แทน
ที่จะแค่ปล่อยให้มันตกลงบนโต๊ะ ลงมาทั้งหัวขึ้นหรือลง ฉันจะโยนเหรียญและจับมัน
กลางอากาศระหว่างฝ่ามือ ตอนนี้เหรียญไม่ใช่หัวขึ้นหรือลง แต่แทนที่จะเป็นแบบนั้นมันหัวซ้ายหรือ
ขวา ดังนั้นตรรกะบอกเราว่าสิ่งนี้ก็ควรมีความน่าจะเป็น 50/50 ที่จะเป็น
หัวซ้ายหรือขวา เพื่อวัดหัวซ้ายหรือขวาบน quantum coin ของเรา เราสามารถทำเหมือนกับที่ทำกับเหรียญคลาสสิก
วัดตามแกนที่ต่างกัน การวัดมาตรฐานของเราบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเป็นไปตามแกนแนวตั้ง
เหมือนกับการวัดหัวขึ้นหรือลงตามปกติของเหรียญคลาสสิก แต่เรายังสามารถถาม quantum coin ของเราว่ามันหัว
ซ้ายหรือขวาได้ด้วย เราเรียกสองสถานะตามแกน x นี้ว่า plus หรือ minus
สำหรับสิ่งนี้เราใช้ Qiskit Primitive ที่เรียกว่า estimator เพื่อทำให้ซับซ้อนขึ้นนิดหน่อย แทนที่จะ return histogram เหมือนที่
sampler ทำ estimator จะให้เรา expectation value ของ observable ใดๆ ของ qubit แทน เพื่อ
ทำความเข้าใจ expectation value นี้ สมมติว่าคุณได้เงินดอลลาร์ทุกครั้งที่เหรียญออกหัว และเสียดอลลาร์เมื่อมัน
ออกก้อย expectation value คือเงินที่คุณคาดว่าจะได้โดยเฉลี่ยในแต่ละการโยนเหรียญ เนื่องจาก
คุณมีโอกาสเท่ากันที่จะได้หรือเสียดอลลาร์ expectation value จะเป็นศูนย์ เหตุผลเดียวกันสามารถใช้กับ
qubit เมื่อเราหา expectation value ของ x เมื่อเราใช้ x กับ plus state เรา
ได้ค่า +1 และกับ minus state เราได้ -1 ดังนั้นถ้าเรามี
distribution 50/50 เราจะได้ expectation value เป็นศูนย์ แต่เราไม่ได้แบบนั้น เราได้ expectation value เป็น +1
ซึ่งหมายความว่าเหรียญถูกวัดว่าเป็น plus ตามแกน x เสมอ มันเหมือนการโยนเหรียญ
จับมัน และรับประกันว่าหัวจะหันไปทางขวาเสมอ เพราะ
superposition ไม่ใช่แค่ probability distribution จำไว้ว่าเราแสดง quantum
state s เท่ากับ C 0 คูณ state 0 บวก C1
คูณ state 1 โดยที่แต่ละ coefficient เหล่านี้เป็น complex หมายความว่ามัน
มีทั้งส่วนจริงและส่วนจินตภาพ ดังนั้นพวกมันบอกเราเกี่ยวกับความน่าจะเป็น แต่ยังซ่อน quantity อีกตัวที่เรียกว่า
phase coefficient บางตัว C สามารถเขียนได้
แบบนี้ โดยที่ C เท่ากับ magnitude คูณกับ phase นี้ โดยที่ phi นี้คือ
phase มันคล้ายกับ phase ของคลื่นหรือตำแหน่งของยอดและร่องของคลื่น ถ้าคลื่นสองอันอยู่ใน phase
กันเพื่อให้ยอดและร่องของพวกมันตรงกัน พวกมันก็จะรวมกันเป็นคลื่นที่สูงสองเท่า
เราเรียกสิ่งนี้ว่า constructive interference ถ้าพวกมัน out of phase เหมือน
แบบนี้ พวกมันก็จะ interfere แบบ destructive ยกเลิกกันอย่างสมบูรณ์ เพื่อดูว่า phase สามารถทำให้
interference เกิดขึ้นใน quantum coin ของเรายังไง มาลองใช้ Hadamard สองครั้งแทนที่จะแค่ครั้งเดียว ตอนนี้แบบคลาสสิก
สิ่งนี้ไม่มีความหมายอะไร ถ้าการใช้ Hadamard เทียบเท่ากับการโยนเหรียญ คุณก็ไม่สามารถโยนเหรียญที่กำลังโยนอยู่ได้ แต่มาดูว่า
เกิดอะไรขึ้นใน quantum mechanically ดังนั้นเราใช้ Hadamard สองครั้งแล้ว sample สถานะที่ได้
น่าทึ่งมาก เราไม่มีความน่าจะเป็น 50/50 อีกต่อไปแล้ว histogram ที่ได้แสดงว่าในทุกกรณีเราวัด
qubit ให้อยู่ใน zero state ดังนั้น Hadamard ตัวที่สองได้ return qubit กลับไปยัง zero state ที่เราเริ่มต้น มัน
ยากนิดหน่อยที่จะเห็นในตอนแรก แต่นี่เป็นเพราะ interference ของ quantum state แต่แทนที่จะ
interfere ในพื้นที่จริงเหมือนคลื่นจริงๆ interference กำลังเกิดขึ้นใน information space ที่เป็นนามธรรมของ qubit
Hadamard ตัวที่สอง gate ทำให้ส่วน zero ของ superposition interfere แบบ constructive ในขณะที่ส่วน one ของ
superposition interfere แบบ destructive และหายไป มาสำรวจเพิ่มเติม เราสามารถเปลี่ยน phase โดยใช้
สิ่งที่เรียกว่า phase gate ดังนั้นตอนนี้มาใช้ Hadamard เพื่อสร้าง superposition ใช้ phase shift ของ
Pi radians แล้วใช้ Hadamard ตัวที่สอง ตอนนี้ดูเหมือนว่า quantum coin ของเราออกมาเป็น state หนึ่งเสมอ
pi phase shift ได้สลับส่วนของ superposition state ที่อยู่ใน phase และ out of phase ซึ่งกันและกัน
ดังนั้น final state จึงเป็น one แทนที่จะเป็น zero มันเหมือนการโยนเหรียญและในขณะที่มันกลางอากาศสามารถ
ใช้ operation ที่รับประกันว่ามันจะออกหัวขึ้นหรือลงเสมอ ขึ้นอยู่กับ
operation เป็นไปไม่ได้ในกรณีคลาสสิก แต่ในกรณีควอนตัมทำได้ สิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้จากการทดลองเหล่านี้คือ
ความสามารถใหม่ของ quantum coin นี้มาจาก phase ซึ่งเป็นคุณสมบัติที่ quantum superposition มี แต่
classical probability distribution ไม่มี ดังนั้นการโยนเหรียญปกติจริงๆ ไม่ใช่ analogy ที่ดีนักสำหรับ
superposition เพราะมันไม่ได้บอกอะไรเกี่ยวกับ phase นี้ ฉันคิดว่าเราทำได้ดีกว่า ฉันจะทำการทดลองอีกอย่าง
กับเหรียญของเรา ฉันมีเหรียญวางอยู่บนโต๊ะหัวขึ้น เพื่อทำให้มันหัวลง ฉันแค่พลิกมันข้าม
นี่เทียบเท่ากับ NOT gate สมมติว่าเราต้องการสร้าง operation ที่ถ้าใช้สองครั้งจะเทียบเท่ากับ
NOT gate นี้ เราสามารถเรียก operation นี้ว่า square root of NOT แล้วคิดดูว่าเราทำอะไรในทางกายภาพ
เมื่อเราใช้ NOT gate เราหมุนมัน 180 องศาตามตัวอย่างแกน x ดังนั้นถ้าเราหมุนเหรียญ
แค่ 90 องศาตามแกน x นั้น ก็จะให้ square root of NOT แก่เรา ดังนั้นเราได้
ใช้ square root of NOT ของเราและเหรียญแค่นั่งอยู่บนขอบ ตอนนี้เราถามได้ว่ามันหัวขึ้นหรือหัวลง ก็
ชัดเจนว่ามันไม่ใช่ทั้งคู่ แต่เราสามารถเพิ่มขั้นตอนในกระบวนการวัดเพื่อบังคับให้มันเป็นหัวขึ้นหรือลง ตอนนี้
เหรียญจะตกไปยังด้านหัวขึ้นหรือลงด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากัน ในหลักการเราสามารถทำนายได้
ว่ามันจะตกแบบไหน แต่ในทางปฏิบัติมันยากพอที่จะทำนายจนถือว่าสุ่มได้ ถ้าฉันต้องการ
วัดว่ามันหัวซ้ายหรือขวา ฉันสามารถบีบมันในทิศทางนั้นในแบบที่คล้ายกัน และมันจะให้ความน่าจะเป็น
50/50 ของซ้ายและขวาอีกครั้ง แต่ในมิตินี้คือหัวหน้าหรือหลัง
หัวหันไปข้างหน้าอยู่แล้ว ดังนั้น 100% ของเวลาเราจะวัดได้หัวหน้า ดังนั้นในขณะที่การวัด x และ z
ให้ผลสุ่ม การวัด y จะให้ผลเดิมเสมอ ถ้าเรานึกถึงการทดลองโยนเหรียญควอนตัมจากส่วนก่อนหน้า
สิ่งนี้คล้ายกับที่ quantum coin ทำหลังจาก
การใช้ Hadamard qubit ถูกวัดให้เป็น zero หรือ 1 ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 50/50 ในทิศทาง Z แต่
เป็น plus state เสมอและไม่เคยเป็น minus state ตามแนว X สิ่งนี้ชี้ให้เห็นว่าบางทีเหรียญที่ยืนนิ่งอยู่บนขอบ
เป็นวิธีที่ดีกว่าในการ visualize สถานะ superposition ของ qubit กว่าเหรียญที่กำลังหมุนในอากาศอย่างบ้าคลั่ง
มาใช้ square root of NOT gate บน quantum coin ของเราใน Qiskit เรามี circuit ง่ายๆ นี้
แล้วเราจะใช้ estimator เพื่อตรวจสอบ expectation value ของ observable สามตัวคือ X, Y และ Z ซึ่งเหมือน
การบีบเหรียญของเราตามแต่ละสามมิติอย่างที่ฉันเพิ่งแสดงไป ดังนั้น expectation value คือ 0,
ลบหนึ่ง และ 0 สำหรับ X, Y และ Z ตามลำดับ นี่คือผลลัพธ์เดียวกับที่เรา
ได้สำหรับการหมุน square root of NOT ที่ใช้กับเหรียญคลาสสิก ในความเป็นจริงมี analogy ที่แม่นยำระหว่าง
เหรียญและสถานะ qubit ตอนนี้เราสามารถ visualize สถานะ qubit เป็นเวกเตอร์ที่ชี้ในทิศทางของหัว
บนเหรียญ ตั้งฉากกับพื้นผิวของเหรียญ ดังนั้นหัวขึ้นหรือ zero state
บน quantum coin เทียบเท่ากับเวกเตอร์ที่ชี้ตรงขึ้น หัวลงหรือ one ชี้ตรงลง และ
superposition เท่ากันของ 0 และ one ชี้ในแนวนอน phase ของ quantum state กำหนด
ทิศทางแนวนอนที่แน่นอนที่ชี้ เช่น ว่ามันชี้ตามแกน x หรือตามแกน Y หรืออยู่ระหว่าง
นั้น เวกเตอร์นี้เรียกว่า Bloch vector และมันกำหนด quantum state ของ qubit เดียวได้อย่างสมบูรณ์และเฉพาะ
เราสามารถจินตนาการ gate ทุกตัวที่เราเคยเห็นในวิดีโอนี้ใหม่ว่าเป็นการหมุนหรือชุดของการหมุนบน
เหรียญหรือเทียบเท่ากับ Bloch vector NOT gate เป็นการหมุน
180 องศาตามแกน x เมื่อใช้กับ zero state หรือหัวขึ้น มันพลิกไปยัง
down state หรือ one square root of NOT แค่ 90 องศาตามแกน x เดิม เริ่ม
จาก heads-up state สิ่งนี้หมุนมันไปยัง heads front phase gate เป็นการหมุนของ phi รอบแกน Z เนื่องจาก
heads up ตรงกับแกน Z สิ่งนี้ไม่ทำอะไรกับเหรียญ Hadamard gate ซับซ้อนกว่านิดหน่อย เรา
เคยเปรียบมันว่าเหมือนการโยนเหรียญ ทำให้เหรียญหมุนควบคุมไม่ได้ในอากาศ แต่ Hadamard จริงๆ แล้วเป็น
การหมุนที่ควบคุมได้และแน่นอนของเหรียญเหมือน gate อื่นๆ ทั้งหมด Hadamard ทำงานโดยหมุน 90 องศา
ตามแกน Y แล้ว 180 องศาตามแกน x ดังนั้นเมื่อใช้กับ heads-up state มัน
กลายเป็น heads-right ดังนั้นไม่มีอะไรสุ่มเลยเกี่ยวกับ quantum superposition state หรือ
operation มาตรฐานใดๆ ที่เราทำกับ qubit ทุก operation เป็นแบบ deterministic และ reversible เพียง
เวลาที่ความสุ่มเข้ามามีบทบาทคือเมื่อเราตัดสินใจวัด quantum state ว่า quantum state อยู่ใน
superposition จริงๆ หรือไม่นั้นขึ้นอยู่กับผู้สังเกตล้วนๆ อย่างที่คุณคงพบเจอมาแล้ว เราสามารถเลือก
coordinate system ของเราได้อย่างอิสระ X, Y และ Z สามารถชี้ตามสามทิศทางที่ตั้งฉากกันใดๆ ดังนั้น
ถ้าเรามี superposition ของ 0 และ one ใน coordinate system หนึ่ง เราสามารถกำหนด coordinate system ใหม่หรือ basis ใหม่
ที่ state ชี้ตาม plus Z Direction อย่างบริสุทธิ์ และจึงไม่ได้อยู่ใน superposition state
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราบอกว่า qubit อยู่ใน superposition เราต้องกำหนด coordinate system หรือ
basis ด้วย คุณอาจออกไปจาก module นี้ด้วยความรู้สึกว่าเราเพิ่งกำจัดความลึกลับทั้งหมดออกจากกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
ท้ายที่สุด หนึ่งในด้านที่ถือว่าแปลกพิสดารที่สุด คือ superposition state ของ qubit ซึ่งจริงๆ แล้วง่ายพอๆ กับเวกเตอร์
สามมิติ แต่จำไว้ว่าเหรียญยังคงเป็นแค่ analogy และแม้แต่ Bloch vector ก็
เป็นแค่ visualization tool เพื่อคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นของผลการวัด เราไม่สามารถบอกได้ว่า quantum
state กำลังทำอะไรจริงๆ ก่อนที่จะถูกวัด เพราะการตรวจสอบสิ่งนั้นต้องใช้การวัด เราจะพูดถึง
ปริศนานี้เกี่ยวกับธรรมชาติที่แท้จริงของ quantum state และว่า quantum entanglement สามารถช่วยเรา
ทำความเข้าใจสิ่งนี้ยังไง ในอีกตอนของ Qiskit in the Classroom เกี่ยวกับ Bell's inequality ในระหว่างนี้ ถ้าคุณ
อยากเล่นกับ quantum coin เพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับ superposition state ของ qubit และวิธีควบคุมพวกมันด้วยตัวเอง
ไปที่ quantum coins module ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบาย ขอบคุณที่ดู แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า